they're like did you get along with
among people in fact oh yeah I had to
man there's a bunch of them they all
look scary
that's my will really
we have a lot of viewers
[Music]
welcome back to a highly essential
episode of careful boys today we got Mr
Sub and Choi
all right we got a very important
question from a fan his name is David
and he wanted to know
how do you tell Asians apart physically
Colleen go
well subin take it away
as an outsider who's been around a lot
of Asians how were you what was your
first time that's [__] I don't
believe you damn okay what's the most
easily identifiable Asian that you think
yeah
the answer is Filipino
no kind of kind of right I mean we're
just darker than most Asians right
Filipinos are hard to tell I'm 30 so
it's easy for me can you believe it
I think Koreans have really strong
features yes but sometimes you can't
tell the difference between Korean and
Japanese depending on if how they dress
I think you can't tell the difference
between anybody we were talking about
like physical qualities physical right
physical office no because like as
a native Asian countries you'll find
that race that looks like the other one
yeah if I go to the Philippines I'll
find a person that looks Japanese Korean
Thai whatever and you go to China like
China you'll find someone that looks
Filipino or whatever like every single
country has their own Spectrum but there
is a look though yeah what's the look
all right like they have a look but it's
really there is a look but the that's
the minority not everyone has that look
right I think like some people look like
a old school racist Japanese cartoon
some of them do yeah and they still wear
the circle glasses what the [__] up
teeth oh yeah like like I've seen
grandpas that look like that like subin
looks Korean right to me right from the
gecko he's Korean yeah so without
knowing his name but if I met him in
Japan oh he's Japanese if I met him in
Vietnam he's Vietnamese if I met him in
Singapore I'm like he's Singapore you
know what I mean it's like every there's
like
Korean but but most oh my God
like every country spectrum is the whole
gamut like if you saw Bart what race
what what kind of in that country like
you might even I wouldn't know about in
the country I would have seen Bard in
Asia let's let's limit it then to just
Asian Americans and here in California I
think in California it's got to be as
racist as possible
like how how do you tell the 180. how do
you tell that somebody's uh Taiwanese
that's a that's a tough usually their
skin light skin like super light skin
stingy
stinging they're very concise mouth
mouth wide open Aspergers
barely like a robotic logical no
emotions they'll say exactly what they
need to say and that's it oh funny okay
no I feel like they're very straight to
the world do you think Bart Jason Cheney
and Jason Chan and all the Taiwanese
people we know have a similarity
I think is there like a lot okay to me I
think a lot of Taiwanese people
are very similar to Jason Chen yeah oh
like Jason Chen to me and my brain the
singer Jason Chen yeah in my brain he
represents a Taiwan Taiwan Pride yeah he
represents a very strong I feel like
you're kind of an anomaly and I feel
like Jason Cheney's a little bit but the
minute I met him I'm like yeah exactly
until until you like talk about their
life and the way they look at things you
could tell like oh you you're talking
but what made you think that the moment
that you met um light skin
big nose oh that's so nice a lot of
stingy
so like when when I was growing up in
San Gabriel I every Chinese person that
I met was telling me they were Taiwanese
and that I didn't find out until later
that some of them just lie
wow and they say they're trying and they
say they're Taiwanese because they don't
want to say they're Mainland Chinese or
Shanghai because you're going to judge
them because like is it better to be
Taiwanese if they told me I wouldn't
give a [__] that's their own [__] I
think I think that's their own that was
the thing that was the thing when I was
in high school is that they would go oh
no I'm not Chinese I'm Taiwanese that's
that's some [__] from their parents or
something it's like it's a thing huh
yeah dude I think so because it's like
why would you feel the need to say that
you know but that's also why I had
trouble telling who was Taiwanese
because I'm like are you lying
the reason why we didn't say what uh
ethnicity we were when we first did
YouTube for like the first 10 years or
more is because I had a theory that they
couldn't tell us apart that's why other
Asians the Asians were just trying to
claim us like this he's Korean he's
whatever but I don't know if we have an
actual like look
a stereotypical look like we can we can
like me and Bart can blend yeah like in
a lot of different what are what are
some things that people have confused
you with with other Asians like
everything everything yeah but I I
mostly got Vietnamese or Korean because
of the accents I did so they thought I
was that but I was also bald now I look
like a like a like a geisha so it I look
like my culture right but you look like
an uncle from Hawaii how do you okay how
do you know someone yeah that's that's
what it looks like how can you tell
somebody's Vietnamese
I think that one's a little harder the
chain yeah
when they have a Jade Buddha that's a
physical yeah that's straight up I think
Vietnamese got bigger eyes bigger eyes
than most Asians sometimes the hair with
the hair the spikiness I think like oh
there's a chance your Viet and then I'm
usually I'm usually right you know who's
the most stereotypical almost racist be
it person I've ever seen Kung Lee The
Fighter
his spinning kicks and all that but he
also looks like a Filipino Uncle too he
loves he looks Filipino to me too yeah
it looks like he's in Ewa Beach yeah I
would have guessed that he was yeah he
looks Filipino or he looks like he could
be Filipino Polynesian Chinese mixed
with a little bit of Japanese
that's right yeah he could if you had a
Polynesian tattoo right you could see
him at like a [__] luau
that's actually why I got tatted it was
I want it to be like different yeah but
you just look Korean though I know
it's like you're like that did nothing I
just realized they didn't do [__] I was
like damn it
I think I think a lot of Korean dudes
have really cool like wavy hair it's the
hair for me I could tell Koreans by
their wavy hairs and then uh I feel like
all the Korean dudes I train they all
have really big calves
not me Korean
big heads yeah they got
they got my shoes
[Music]
yeah and nice hair is mine's big yeah
how do you get wavy hair yeah you got a
perm no pearls no Perma no perm but like
last natural Mike's song David they got
big ass hits yup yeah they do have big
foreheads they do they do yeah
damn strong hairline with a big old
forehead can you guys tell the
difference between Filipino and
Cambodian when I can yeah they're
standing next to each other I can yeah
how how what's the difference chembling
is way darker okay
it's a different kind of dark it's a
different kind of dark oh cambodians are
like they're meant to like exist in the
Sun and in Filipinos are like
it's too hot they try not to huh what
about Indonesians what if you threw
Indonesia do you think that changes
that's hard too because they were really
light-skinned yeah something really like
it's they're on either end of the
spectrum yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel like
Filipino Malaysian Indonesian all the
islands right there it's hard for me
it's hard to tell unless you see what
they're wearing like the facial features
and stuff I can't tell some some Thai
guys too yeah tiger crazy I think East
Asians are way easier to figure out
younger Asians right yeah like the
jungle Asians the jungle Asians those
are harder like the island Asians
no it's cool
yeah but like the island Asians like the
ones that live in islands like they they
look a lot more similar than I feel like
the way I could tell Koreans apart from
Japanese is is their hair they have none
they don't have body hair oh yeah yeah
oh yeah they're Salamence Japanese dudes
I feel like are kind of hairy bro yeah
yeah these guys got a lot of like yeah
like they're like the chimpanzees of
Asia like you know the Japanese monkeys
that
that just looks like old grandpas you
know you can't tell the difference
between the Japanese monkeys and the hot
spring
dude there's a picture of three Japanese
grandpas like eating ice cream and they
look like three chimps it's it's pretty
funny is that a famous photo yeah it's
like a meme yeah like Japanese Brown
scream yeah it's freaking hilarious to
me they look like yeah Colleen when you
whenever you meet a new Asian person do
you have a game in your head where you
go I'm gonna guess what kind of Asian
they are no but now I do damn dude
because I do that all the time I try to
figure you out do you do that three I
already know you already know yeah I
already know and then I go if if it's
not if it doesn't match I'm like you
need to get to me
your life has been alive yeah you know
what race is really hard to tell yeah
yeah yeah I don't even I don't even know
what mums were yeah so Sacramento are
there moms in Hawaii not really no
there's none in Hawaii but I went to
Sacramento and then I went to a park
they got a [__] ton I think they got a
look yeah they're they're shorter and
they're stocky like I don't know any
tall Hmong people they're like they got
a yeah they're like um they're like I
would say like average five six five
five yes and then they're like they're
like sturdy looking they're not fat
they're like some of them are but yeah
yeah but yeah but you know what I mean
right they're not like there's
exceptions yeah yeah we just got like
wider joints or something yeah they they
see like facially a lot of Hmong people
look to me like they have a hardcore
like indigenous look yeah yeah they're
stalking like like if you were casting
you know like uh like a war ancient war
movie they all look like they book it no
I agree like I feel like some a lot of
Asians you see look more Americanized or
look more westernized yeah but they look
like they've retained like the right
[__] yeah I couldn't tell what they were
I was like Vietnamese Chinese they're
like did you get along with Hmong people
in SEC oh yeah I had to man there's a
bunch of them scary too oh [__] that's
all I had to that's my will really
we have a lot of viewers
[Laughter]
do you ever like meet a new Asian person
and then you guess in your head and when
they tell you what kind of Asian they
are you're surprised yeah Mongolian
Mongolian's always really like
surprising I've like I think I've met
zero Mongolian I don't know I'm at zero
I met zero if they look Chinese and they
start speaking Russian you're like
you're from Kazakhstan that's Kazakhstan
oh yeah like those kinds but yeah I
don't really know any Mongolians I don't
think yeah I've never met mango you met
Mongolian yeah one girl I met who was
Mongolia and there was a zero percent
chance I would have guessed it she has a
big head too huh mongolia's got big
heads too no you don't have a big head
I would never say that oh I wouldn't say
that about you your head is totally
normal oh dude your head's cool
Gilbert's Filipino but he has a big hat
he got a Mongolian head yeah I mean yeah
no I'm not that's not what I meant he's
got a Korean no it's full Filipino yeah
he has big eyes for being Filipino
absolutely dude his sister too they got
they got he got he got like the jeans
that everybody wants see I don't know
like with Gilbert if if there's like a
multiple choice like right off the bat
I'd be like nope not Cambodia not into
like it was just circle Filipino for
sure but I don't know what it is but I
just look at him like okay it's my
original thing though you know what it
is for well it's hard it's not physical
for me but like his sense of humor when
with the first time he opened his mouth
and I heard it I was like this guy's
Filipino dude you gotta meet his dad his
dad Gilbert senior hot [__] the
hottest guy the hottest dad he's a
handsome man you no he looks one he
looks just like Gilbert oh yeah lick on
my lips and then two he's he's kind of
does he got a booty like Gilbert because
Gilbert's ass is pretty juicy Gilbert
senior got a [__] donk on him dude
um but he's so [__] funny he's he's
hilarious he's like Gilbert like you
understand that's where he gets it okay
he opened up for Jared De Guzman telling
like a bunch of like what yeah yeah is
that opened up for Jared
I told a bunch of these jokes and he's
so [__] funny how do you tell the
singaporeans apart I have no [__]
idea usually I wait for to hear them
talk as soon as they they talk then you
could I aren't they just Chinese yeah
the spectrum is crazy Malay to Chinese
and it's like the blend look that's part
of the reason why I did 23andMe is
because my mom she speaks so many
different languages and she says like oh
our grandma's uh Indonesian or whatever
the [__] like I wanted to like get down
to the bottom of like what are we really
and then it was very underwhelming
because we're just like at that point
you just don't care yeah well you know
what's difficult too in the ocean oh
yeah the ocean's difficult because we
don't see enough of them that's the
other thing that's the other part of the
equation I like be on the west coast I
had a friend in elementary school who
brought his dad's hunting knife and got
in trouble because he wanted for show
and tell because we had to all bring
things for show and tell and he's a
Laotian boy
he busted out his dad's hunting knife
and then all the kids were like whoa and
then the teacher was like Daddy
dad put that away
people like it's just so cool to see
like like centuries catching people are
pretty good looking dude centuries of
mixing is so cool yeah
they're like Russian and Chinese yeah
that's a pretty bombastic it's bomb ass
that's yeah you mix Asian with anything
you get a pretty good look I think yeah
I don't know
what's uh combination is not so good no
lined up and you have to guess they're
raised by their dicks I think that'd be
hard suckability you'd probably have to
rule that out first that's hard I don't
know is it hard you want to look at it
hard no no no no just natural just
dangling just dangling put all the darts
with darts lights with lights I think
all of our dicks are dogs yeah I think
all of them are Dark yeah because even
if we're light-skinned our Dick's pretty
dark you ever meet an Asian guy with
pink nipples
there was a top ten
um they did a 2023 like survey on Dick
sizes between like everyone in the world
yes and the the bottom ten for like the
shortness are all Asian let's go Nick
let's go baby I think Koreans is the
last one right they are the smallest
ones
they are in the they are in that ten
the spare the bottom 10. the smallest
ones is Thailand really yeah it goes
Thai what are you talking about you see
the lady and then North Korea which
seems like propaganda yeah that seems
like are you sure yeah they're just
talking [__] I've seen some lady boys
with big asses me too
is
the chosen ones but yeah in Thailand
you this is um erect links Thailand got
3.7 inches average no way dude 3.7 it
was at least here when I left
but uh North Korea got 3.8 Cambodia 3.9
Nepal 3.9 why how would North Korea like
join this worldwide statistics
that's a priority we're sending you into
North Korea but you're just gonna look
at Dicks yeah the Guinness world of
records like yeah I don't know who was
in there what in tarnation or did they
just like phone a friend and just like
ask and then me and Mar got four inches
Laos got four inches Vietnam for Sri
Lanka four inches South Korea 4.3 hey
oh no the top is Sudan Sudan Sudanese
that makes sense yeah and then Dr Congo
that's 7.1 average in because a lot of
Sudanese are like six six wait where's
America
dude that's hitting my cervix for sure
they're not in the top ten they're not
in the top 10 because there's too many
Asian Americans
damn we're bringing down the average
fudge
yeah and then it's Ecuador and then uh
yeah Republic of the Congo Ghana Nigeria
Venezuela Lebanon Colombia Cameroon saw
that coming
you did whose job is it to acquire the
data I know there's a worldwide dick
measure yeah I'm sure that they just go
on medical records basically probably is
that on our chart you guys don't get
your dictionary my dick size not on my
medical records it's not wait I don't
even know should I call my [__] Blue
Cross to ask I thought you have to write
it in your DMV form yeah I'm like how
are they measuring it hard yeah because
right when you sign up as an organ donor
they go what's the length of your organ
they're like oh we won't need that one
wait a minute they didn't ask me that
does it affect your insurance premium if
it's big or small yeah higher chance of
STDs everyone's just gonna be nicer to
you if it's bigger I think not everyone
people from uh Myanmar that's a hard one
yeah I've only met one person and then
they were Chinese so that doesn't even
count
to like always bring up the fact that
like Asians can't always tell Asians
apart either like that's all like for
sure there's a look but then the
spectrum is also so big it's it's hard
to be a hundred percent yeah yeah but
there's a look for sure right you gotta
look for other Clues like Joe said
somewhere in there there's the
stereotypical guy representative of like
each of those things oh yeah for sure I
met guys that look like old racist
cartoon drawings of Chinese guys and
they're Chinese and I started laughing
in their face this was in China no here
it's a Monterey Park baby
[Music]
laughs